[Musique]
imaginez
en 2 1 2 3 4 5 6
2 mètres par 6 m les dimensions
intérieures classique d'une panne yahoo
ce
voile à l'espace que vous avez à
disposition pour faire tenir tout ce que
vous possédez toutes vos possessions
toute votre vie toute votre maison
est ce que ça vous paraît désirable
pour moi oui je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
entre mai 21 m et 25 ans j'ai vécu dans
différentes pays pour des stages ou des
morceaux de mes études
à chacun de ses voyages je suis parti
avec une valise de 23 kg
et ça a été le déclic pour moi quand
j'ai réalisé qu'en fait cette valise
contenait tout ce dont j'avais besoin
pour vivre bien
et que du coup tout ce que j'avais
laissé derrière moi dans la maison mes
parents étaient finalement superflu
c'est aussi pendant ces années là qu'a
grandi en moi à vitesse grand v une
conscience écologique
j'ai entendu les cris d'alarmé des
scientifiques qui nous alerte sur les
limites planétaires qu'on a déjà dépassé
ou qu'on est en train de dépasser
dérèglement climatique
effondrement de la biodiversité
acidification des océans pollution
chimique dégradation des sols épuisement
des ressources et j'en passe
j'ai réalisé que l'abondance matérielle
dans laquelle je vivais été en grande
partie responsable de tout ça
alors je suis rentré en france
j'ai décidé d'arrêter de prendre l'avion
et j'ai poursuivi mon voyage sur le
chemin du minimalisme
je me suis lancé pleinement dans le
mouvement des ténias ou en créant un
village en bretagne le petit village
en parallèle j'ai élu domicile sur un
petit voilier de 7 mètres de long pour
l'eau chaude
et ensuite dans martin en camion aménagé
je suis passée d'environ 12 mètres
carrés pour la taille ni à environ six
mètres carrés pour le voilier jusqu'à
moins de 4 mètres carrés à 2 pour le
vanneau
et j'ai vécu super heureuse dans chacun
de ces micro habitats
le modèle de réussite actuelle nous
pousse à désirer une maison toujours
plus grande
quand je cherche à acheter ou à louer
souvent je commence par regarder mon
budget
combien d'argent elle à disposition et
qu'elle est la plus grande surface que
je puisse m'offrir dans ce budget là
quand on fait le choix du micro habitats
la logique est complètement différente
on commence par se demander quelles sont
mes besoins fondamentaux
qu'est ce qui est non négociable pour
moi
de quoi est-ce que j'ai véritablement
besoin pour être heureuse
au moment de concevoir ma taille nous
c'était clair que ce qui était important
pour moi c'était de pouvoir accueillir
mes amis partager un repas avec eux
alors quand j'ai dessiné les plans j'ai
conçu deux plans de travail suffisamment
grand et un coin salon salle à manger où
on puisse tenir à 6o à 8,6 et vraiment
des bons potes
concevoir son micro habitats à partir de
ses besoins est un travail
d'introspection
exigeant et enrichissant qui nous force
à nous connaître sur notre manière de
fonctionner au quotidien jusque dans les
moindres détails
parce que quand l'espace est restreint
on peut rien laisser au hasard
par exemple moi j'aime faire mes courses
et en vrac et tous rangés dans des
bocaux en verre ok mais au quotidien de
combien de bocaux elle besoin et quelle
longueur d'étagères mais faut-il pour
les accueillir de combien ai-je besoin
de cendre dans ma penderie combien ce
que je possède deux paires de chaussures
une fois que j'ai terminé ce travail
d'introspection
c'est aussi un exercice intellectuel
stimulant de créativité et d'ingéniosité
pour agencer mais essentiel dans un
espace réduit
on est obligé de exploiter l'espace dans
ses trois dimensions utiliser les murs
le plafond multiplier les
fonctionnalités
par exemple dans un espace de 1 mètre
par un mètre on peut faire tenir un
frigo un millier un égouttoir avait
celle des étagères sur les murs et en os
en mezzanine un bout deux lits et de
table de chevet
est-ce que vous avez chez vous des
tiroirs des placards ou des sacs qui
sont toujours un peu pénible à fermer
parce qu'ils sont trop plein
alors évidemment quand on fait le choix
du micro habitats un moment donné il
faut faire le vide
se débarrasser de tout ce qui encombre à
notre vie pour se recentrer sur
l'essentiel
si un objet m'apporte une joie profonde
alors je peux le garder mais si un objet
m'inspire du stress du malaise voire du
dégoût alors je m'en sépare
et contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser du coup être minimaliste ne veut
pas forcément dire ne rien posséder
on peut être minimaliste et avoir un
beau piano chez soi
on peut avoir une grande bibliothèque si
la lecture est quelque chose qui compte
sincèrement profondément pour moi
je peux avoir du matériel de kitesurf si
le kite surf c'est ma passion
la magie de micro habitats tient au fait
qu'ils nous poussent à questionner la
place de chaque chose dans notre vie
quand j'étais au lycée j'allais très
souvent faire du shopping presque tous
les week-ends
et je me rappelle que je pouvais passer
des heures le matin devant ma garde-robe
avec une angoisse profonde
de ne pas savoir quoi en fils est
tellement il y avait deux choix
aujourd'hui cette angoisse m'a quitté
j'ai une tenue pour mes interventions
professionnelles et c'est ma préférée
alors quand je me balade en ville
je me sens libre de ne pas ressentir de
désir pour tous que les vitrines
voudrait m'offrir avoir je sais en fait
que j'ai pas besoin de tout ça et puis
en plus je vais pas la place chez moi et
en fait j'en ai même plus envie alors
quand je me balade en ville je suis
libre d'observer et d'écouter les bruits
de sentir le vent le soleil sur ma peau
de rêver mon esprit est tranquille
on devrait systématiquement se poser la
question pourquoi j'achète ça
est-ce que je l'achète parce que
véritablement j'en ai besoin
ou est-ce que je l'achète pas ce que
j'ai l'habitude de faire ça
ou parce que tout le monde autour de moi
c'est comme ça
ou peut-être parce que une stratégie
marketing a fonctionné sur moi
moi j'ai posé cette question pour
beaucoup de choses qui étaient présentes
dans ma vie
le soutien-gorge
la crème hydratante le parfum la pince à
épiler le crayon sur les yeux les talons
aiguilles
et j'ai expérimenté qu'est ce qui se
passe si j'enlève ça de ma vie
en fait ça a rendu ma vie beaucoup plus
simple beaucoup plus légère
le matin je me lève j'enfile la seule
tenue qui traîne au pied de mon lit et
je suis prête à mourir au monde
j'ai l'impression d'avoir retrouvé une
forme de souveraineté
en mettant sur chaque geste de
consommation la conscience de comment ça
va affecter ma vie
une grande maison peut aussi souvent
être source de tracas la quantité
d'objets et volume à jerry constitue une
charge mentale
mon esprit est sans arrêt interpellé par
des objets qui nécessite de l'attention
de l'entretien il faut que j'aille
ranger là il faut que j'aille nettoyer
là bas que je ris par ça et que leur
achète ça jusqu'à parfois devenir
presque esclaves de nos propres
possessions
dans un micro habitats chaque chose est
parfaitement à sa place et requiert un
minimum d'attention
dans une taille ni en cinq minutes je
peux avoir nettoyé tout le sol de ma
maison et si vraiment je me motive à
faire une demi-journée de ménage alors
ma maison sera impeccable de fond en
comble mais littéralement murs plafonds
intérieurs des tiroirs y compris
et
quand on vit dans un habitat
surdimensionné et qu'on est fatigué on a
besoin de se reposer alors on part en
vacances loin de sa maison pour se
ressourcer
mais notre maison n'est-elle pas
l'endroit au monde qui devrait être le
plus à même de nous reposer
chaque micro habitats dans lequel j'ai
vécu a été pour moi un véritable temple
de sérénité ils m'ont apporté plus
d'énergie qu'ils m'en ont demandés
ils n'ont permis simplement d'être là
et dans la charge mentale des
possessions il ya aussi la peur de la
perte
la peur de se faire cambrioler quand on
possède des bijoux du matériel high tech
ou d'autres objets de valeur chez soi
moi le seul objet je serais vraiment
d'été de le perdre c'est mon ordinateur
parce que c'est mon principal outil de
travail mais là déjà bientôt dix ans il
est plus très attractif du coup je sais
que si les cambrioleurs venez chez moi
il serait très déçu du détour n'avoir
rien à perdre c'est aussi une grande
source de tranquillité d'esprit
l'accumulation de possession matérielle
peut véritablement devenir parfois
fardeau un frein dans nos vies un
obstacle à nos rêves
on voit des personnes qui sont pas
épanouis dans leur situation mais qui
reste comme prisonnière dans l'idée d'un
déménagement paraît insurmontable tant
il y as d'affaires à gérer ça prendrait
des semaines des mois parfois
en limitant ce qui m'appartient je sais
que je suis capable de déménager et
réaménagé ailleurs le tout en 24 heures
top chrono
du coup je peux rester ouverte aux
opportunités qui se présentent et suivre
en permanence mon élan de vie
j'ai 27 ans et j'ai l'impression d'avoir
déjà vécu plusieurs vies
et dans la liberté ya aussi la liberté
financière
tout l'argent que je n'ai plus à
dépenser pour des choses dont je n'ai
plus besoin ben j'ai plus besoin de le
gagner
ma sécurité financière devient d'autant
plus facile à assurer
alors je suis libre de choisir mes
activités professionnelles en fonction
du sens qu'elles ont pour moi plutôt
qu'en fonction de leur rémunération
et je m'affranchis de la pression
sociale à gravir les échelons pour aller
chercher un salaire toujours plus
importants
laissez moi vous dire encore une chose
quand je suis dans une taille ni d'un
voilier ou dans un camion aménagé il n'y
a littéralement tient pas qui me
séparent de l'extérieur
où que je sois dans ma maison je suis
tout au plus avec quelques dizaines de
centimètres d'une fenêtre
alors chaque coup de vent chaque goutte
de pluie chaque rayon de soleil chaque
nuage je les vois je les sens passe et
je suis ultra connectés à ce qui
m'entoure
débarrasser du superflu cheville encore
plus disponible pour moi même pour les
autres pour le monde
en fait j'ai moins de surface habitable
mais en réalité j'ai plus d espace
l'espace extérieur le monde et des
espaces intérieurs mon intériorité m
il ya quelques jours j'ai revendu le
camion aménagé que j'avais achetée il ya
j'ai réalisé que lui aussi c'était
devenu une charge mentale et que en fait
c'était dissonant pour moi par rapport à
mes convictions écologiques de me
déplacer dans deux tonnes 5 de métal et
de plastique propulse aux hydrocarbures
j'ai réalisé que j'étais plus heureuse
en me déplaçant en stop avec une tente
dans mon sac à dos
alors c'est moins confortable certes
mais c'est beaucoup plus riche aventure
de rencontre et super épanouissant par
le sentiment d'alignement que ça me
procure
aujourd'hui bien que je sois diplômé de
l'école polytechnique
je n'ai pas de bel appartement parisien
je n'ai pas d'emprunt je n'ai pas de
voiture je n'ai pas de télé je n'ai pas
de montre connectés je n'ai pas de ses
cheveux
en revanche j'ai une vie riche de belles
relations
familiales
amicales
professionnelles
amoureuse
ma vie est sobre matériellement mais
riche humainement et intérieurement
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous inviter à
vous questionner sur vos besoins
fondamentaux
c'est quoi vos essentiel
est ce qu'il ya des choses dans votre
vie dont vous pourriez vous délester
et je vous invite à imaginer ce qui se
passerait si demain
on a arrêté de penser en termes
d'accumulation matériel
six fois vous nous tous ont commencé à
donner plutôt qu'à acheter
à vide est plutôt qu'à remplir
à se débarrasser d'eux plutôt qu à
collectionner
si plutôt que de désirez acheter des
choses on désirait vivre des choses
si plutôt que d'offrir à nos proches des
cadeaux on leur offrait du temps la
qualité de présence
des moments authentiques
si on arrêtait d'accumuler à l'extérieur
pour grandir à l'intérieur
si on décide est de posséder moins pour
exister plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]